welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and the final
quantumania trailer just dropped giving
us even more to speculate on and worry
about like dear God Paul Rudd is getting
his ass kicked by Kang as a father
there's no one more important to Scott
Lang than his daughter Cassie and after
missing out on most of her childhood
Ant-Man is determined to recoup the time
he's lost this video is brought to you
by Squarespace more on them later the
trailers to the promotional material
showing off Cassie's suit and up it's
clear that she's gonna play a big role
in this film so today I'm going to hit
you with everything you need to know
about Cassie Lane going into Ant-Man 3
from the MCU history refresher to her
comic history trajectory so Scott if
you're watching this you totally don't
have to make a devil's bargain with Kang
I'll catch you up on what she's been up
to let's start with her MCU iteration
one of the biggest questions I had after
watching this trailer was how old is
Cassie supposed to be again I am already
bad enough at math without the blip and
the first Ant-Man we saw Cassie
celebrating her eighth birthday in July
of 2015. with wakanda forever set in the
year 2025 will be in the year 2026 for
quantumania making Cassie almost 19
years old director Peyton Reed confirmed
that Cassie is 18 in this movie saying
quote it occurred to us well Cassie's
going to be 18 in this movie that's
great I love the idea of Scott still
relating to Cassie as a kid but she's
not she's a young adult now she has her
own ideas of what it means to do good in
the world and she's trying to find her
voice as a hero she can also be a little
critical of her father something tells
me that Scott's gonna be a little
critical of some of his daughter's
choices too in the trailer we see Cassie
being let out of a jail cell likely
because she decided to follow in her
dad's footsteps if you recall from the
first Ant-Man got was initially arrested
for burgling millions of corrupt dollars
and redistributing the wealth my guess
is that Cassie's found her own form of
vigilante justice and is getting
arrested for technically doing the right
thing but doing it super illegally sorry
Daddy-o but you pulled a Robin Hood and
now your sweet baby girl wants to go
full Little John Cassie's arrest may
even be the Catalyst for Scott's
determination to make up for lost time I
can imagine that he probably feels like
damn if I was around to raise her May
maybe she wouldn't be on The Slammer
right now I'm sure he feels responsible
for the choices Cassie's now making as a
young adult despite the truth even if he
was around for Cassie's teenage years
her dad's job is just too cool and she
probably would have insisted on going
into the family business regardless a
recurring tragedy of Cassie's
relationship with her father both in the
MCU and in the comics is that while they
have a close unbreakable Bond they're
also doomed to only have short windows
of time to spend with one another in the
MCU got does three years of hard time
for stealing from vistacorp after a year
outside the clink gets sentenced to two
years of house arrest pretty much
immediately after he's a free man once
more he gets trapped in the quantum
realm for five years add this together
with his spotty shared custody and it
seems like Scott has only been an active
part of his daughter's life for roughly
eight out of her 18 years it's
speculation but I can also imagine that
the Press tours and podcasting that
Scott's been doing post endgame have
also cut into quality time with his
daughter in the comics this twist of
fate is pretty much the same early in
Cassie's life Scott is convicted of a
burglary missing out on some of her
formative years shortly after getting
out of prison he discovers that she has
a heart defect this puts him on the path
to become the second Ant-Man as a means
to cure her but it's not without its
stints fighting villains in exotic
Faraway locations when Cassie's in her
early teens Scott dies in an explosion
at Avengers Mansion thanks to a
grief-stricken Scarlet Witch's unstable
reality warping in the aftermath we
learned that Cassie's been stealing her
dad's pimp particles for years hoping to
develop powers and she does in fact
Cassie's Pim irradiated heart allows her
to shrink and grow at will without the
need of pimtek to honor Scott's memory
teenage Cassie becomes the superhero
stature a founding member of the Young
Avengers look Monday is we're going to
get back to the video in one second but
I gotta tell you about Squarespace not
only are they making it possible for me
to do this video but they could be
making it possible for you to do like
honestly whatever you want to do online
that's because Squarespace makes it easy
to make an awesome website that lets you
engage with your audience and sell
anything you need your products content
you create and even your time
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
for building your brand and growing your
business online if you're into making
videos Squarespace can help you create
Pro level videos effortlessly the
Squarespace video studio app will help
you make and share engaging videos to
tell your story grow your audience and
drive sales but hey maybe videos aren't
your thing because you're more of a
social media buff no problem you can
display posts from any profile you want
on your website and automatically push
website content to your favorite social
media channels so your followers can
share it too no matter what you're doing
squarespace's analytic tools will help
you learn where your traffic and sales
are coming from so that you can improve
your website and build a marketing
strategy based either on your top
keywords or most popular products and
content head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com new
rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain during
the events of 2010s the Children's
Crusade the Young Avengers are
transported back in time to the day that
Scott was killed Cassie manages
displaced Scott to the Future moments
before the explosion saving him but
making it appear as if he had perished
for all those years unfortunately Cassie
herself dies at the hands of Dr Doom in
the same art Scott would then spend
years carrying the pain of surviving at
the cost of his daughter's life with him
in 2014. Dr Doom turned good for a spell
and used a reality warping wish to undo
his murder and resurrect Cassie after
spending a publishing decade torn apart
Scott and Cassie were finally alive
together at the same time but even
though Cassie was resurrected that
didn't mean she got to spend much time
with her dad as a means of protecting
Cassie both Scott and her mother Peggy
agreed to keep her away from superheroes
but like her MCU counterpart Comet
Cassie has a knack for finding trouble
and a desire to follow in her father's
giant slash tiny footsteps
post-resurrection Cassie struggles with
no longer being a young Avenger while
her friends like Kate Bishop are off
fighting on the West Coast Avengers
Cassie gets into fights at her new
school which land her in trouble behind
her mother's back she starts hanging out
with dear old dad who uses pin particles
casually for things like turning cell
phones and toy boxes into movie theaters
deciding to go Rogue Cassie joins a
taskrabbit service for super villains to
get her powers back and takes out the
old power Brokers operation from the
inside in the aftermath her parents
agree to let her follow her passion to
fight crime as long as it's supervised
by Scott nowadays Cassie operates in a
duo with Ant-Man under the Alias stinger
and I believe that we're likely to see a
similar Dynamic on screen for
quantumania for starters on a surface
level I think MCU Cassie is probably
going to be picking up the code name
Stinger as it's her current comic book
identity and her movie color scheme is
more in line with her stinger costume
than her stature one but in a broader
sense this father-daughter team has the
push and pull of a mentor trying to
teach his Protege how to not make the
same mistakes he's made and a young
upstart desperate to prove that she has
what it takes to get into the big
leagues I wouldn't be surprised if this
is how we see MCU Cassie interact with
Scott in the quantum realm as he
desperately tries to protect her from
Kang while she rushes headfirst into
danger possibly not only to prove that
she can keep up with him but also to fix
her mistake of sucking the ant family
into the quantum realm it also wouldn't
be a shocker to find out that all her
early movie Quantum research happens
behind her mother's back with PEG
expressly forbidding Cassie from playing
with Pim particles while it'll
definitely be fun to see Scott try to
Wrangle a daughter who knows how to
playfully push his dorky buttons it
clearly isn't gonna be all fun and games
like I've said Cassie and Scott have a
habit of only being in each other's
lives for brief Windows of time so
weather Kang actually does squash Scott
like a bug or that's all a trailer
misdirect I do think that this
father-daughter duo will be broken up
once again by the end of the film with
the MCU building up a roster of
potential Young Avengers including
Cassie I think that the makings of a
Children's Crusade adaptation are in the
cards for us this means the Cassie will
likely be motivated to save her father
from his lose-lose battle against Kang
if Scott is killed or even displaced in
the quantum realm this could be the
Catalyst that causes Cassie to put the
Young Avengers together in future MCU
projects like her Arcus stature in the
comics Cassie will be driven to save
Scott and while I think she'll
ultimately succeed I really hope it
doesn't cost her what it does in the
comments follow me on Instagram and
Twitter whitneypuppy Fallen Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
[Music]